un jour vous allez voir Elvire Popesco
la grande Elvire Popesco elle vous dit
pauvre con tu ne dois pas faire ce
métier de journaliste tu dois faire
acteur
vous enlevez pas votre montre là non
pourquoi parce que votre père vous avez
dit au sujet des interviews quand on se
donne on donne son temps donc on enlève
ça monte c'est un très bon conseil
enlever la faites-moi plaisir et mon
papa voilà Obélix à votre père donc
justement la pièce que vous commencez le
6 février au Théâtre de la Porte
Saint-Martin s'appelle conversation avec
mon père donc voilà de herbe Gardner
alors l'adaptation est faite par
Jean-Claude Grimbert mise en scène de
Marcel bluval voilà alors l'auteur de
conversation avec mon père c'est herbes
Gardner qui est l'un des trois ou quatre
grands auteurs dramatiques américains
des 50 dernières années c'est lui qui a
fait des clowns par milliers qui a été
joué par Yves Montand et que beaucoup de
succès à l'époque je ne suis pas
Rapoport qui était joué par Jacques
dufilo et cette pièce conversation avec
mon père
permet de le signaler parce que c'est
important il est quand même aussi un des
grands scénaristes américains on lui
doit alldre à jazz et la Liste de
Schindler ce qui est pas mal l'histoire
c'est l'histoire d'un père et deux fils
l'un d'entre eux trouvé par Serge
azanavicius vous vous êtes le Patron
juif d'un bistrot new-yorkais qui a
débarqué de dessin en 1936 sous le nom
de Isaac Goldberg et qui en fait se fait
appeler Eddy Ross mais qui veut
s'intégrer dans la société américaine
mais qui reproche à son fils de de
perdre ses racines quoi voilà c'est un
peu simple c'est un des deux thèmes de
la pièce parce que je pense que dans
toutes les grandes pièces il y a
toujours plusieurs thèmes qui sont
abordés le thème de l'immigration vu
sous un angle très particulier où on
démontre la différence qu'il y a entre
la première génération des migrés et
puis les les seconds les générations
suivantes et c'est en général la
première génération des vies ce qui est
mon cas ce qui est mon cas dans dans la
pièce tout touchant il veut changer de
nom il change d'architecture il change
de nourriture il change de langage
c'est terrible c'est eux qui défriche le
terrain tandis que la seconde génération
ils sont chez eux voilà lui il fait tout
pour être quelqu'un alors que ses
enfants sont américains d'emblée d'une
certaine et le deuxième thème qui est
d'abord
ça qui me fait plaisir de la pièce
s'intéresse les les jeunes c'est le
problème des rapports entre un père et
un fils c'est à dire que l'erreur
commise souvent par amour par les
parents c'est de vouloir pousser leurs
enfants dans la direction qu'ils veulent
eux sans essayer plutôt de de de trouver
ce pourquoi ils sont doués et on le rôle
que j'interprète est un échec complet
puisque je voulais que je veux que mon
fils soit de l'un devienne la véritable
américain alors il devient effectivement
un véritable américain un peu stylisé
sur le travailleur gagnant du pognon
puis finalement je m'aperçois que les
mecs qui bossent comme des dingues qui
ne dorment que quand ils prennent un
taxi et qui deviennent milliardaire sont
des gens qui m'emmerdent et de l'autre
je veux faire aussi un vrai américain je
vais en faire un héros je l'envoie à la
guerre il est tué donc deux échecs c'est
génial ce qui est génial
Claude c'est qu'en vieillissant vous
avez vraiment de plus en plus la voix de
votre père et l'autre jour vous avez
appelé vous m'avez laissé un message sur
mon répondeur et j'entends allô ce
brasseurs et d'un seul coup je me suis
j'ai l'impression d'être mort et au
paradis et d'entendre Pierre Brasseur
c'est vrai que chez les brasseurs la
comédie c'est une histoire de famille on
connaît puisque votre fils Alexandre
brasseur bah ça marche très bien pour
lui bah j'espère en me disant que ça va
marcher on peut pas ça commence bien il
était dans Maigret avec Bruno Kremer sur
France 2 hier il écrit un court métrage
qui raconte la difficulté de dire je
t'aime à son père mais il dit c'est pas
du tout autobiographique quand on
interview parce qu'il dit avec mon père
ça va très bien on s'appelle
pratiquement tous les jours voilà
on va parler de votre vie
[Musique]
vous êtes né en 1936 à Neuilly vous êtes
le fils d'audette joyeux de Pierre
Brasseur vous faites partie de d'une
dynastie du théâtre qui remonte à
l'époque de la restauration à 1820 1820
alors le premier brasseur c'était le
créateur du Théâtre des Nouveautés après
il y a eu Jules directeur du Théâtre des
Variétés son frère Albert comédien
vedette alors votre vrai nom est le vrai
nom de votre père c'est pas brasseur
c'est Espinasse et là on va parler de
votre vrai grand-père qui était un
personnage assez extraordinaire c'est
que votre grand-mère a eu donc cet
enfant avec Monsieur Espinasse qui était
Pierre Brasseur votre père alors c'était
quoi c'était un gigolo magnifique quoi
un très beau mec était très beau et puis
d'abord ma grand-mère qui était
comédienne également mais celle de
l'énervait parce que elle se prenait
elle était une artiste mais ça se voyait
pas alors pour que on sache que c'était
une artiste elle avait remplacé son sac
à main par une boîte à violon mais au
moins comme ça on va me prendre pour une
artiste mais là il y a un très beau
jeune homme qui
qui lui a fait la cour dans un autobus
et qu'il a sur l'Impérial de l'autobus
et quand votre père racontait l'histoire
à Jacques Brel il l'a mis dans le
refrain de sa célèbre chanson Bruxelles
c'est quand même extraordinaire et il a
invité il vient me voir au théâtre alors
il doit donner des tickets elle est allé
loin le cherche encore parce que c'est
depuis les mois qu'un figurant albardier
qui était dire que en fait il était il
était l'amant de Sarah Bernhardt il y
avait un théâtre il avait fait croire à
votre grand-mère qui était une grande
vedette du théâtre voilà ce qui fait
qu'il a dû excusez-moi l'expression la
sauter dans la loge et que votre père
est né Pierre Brasseur est né ainsi
voilà mais un jour comme mon père jouait
kind au théâtre Sarah Bernard on est
resté un peu avec le concierge on a fait
le tour on est monté dans dans les loges
en haut il m'a dit je sors certainement
d'une de ces loges là voilà alors cette
Espinasse est mort à 24 ans d'une
cirrhose du foie et votre père
comme vous a pris le nom de jeune fille
de sa grand-mère c'est-à-dire brasseur
voilà exact voilà alors votre mère c'est
au d'être joyeux évidemment
qui a été célèbre par Entrée des
artistes par douce par le mariage de
chiffon enfin des films qui sont des
monuments voilà et quand votre père la
rencontre d'être joyeux elle a 18 ans
c'est sur le tournage de grisou et lui
il est séduit par sa fraîcheur il n'ose
pas la toucher
il a considéré comme un enfant et elle
dit dans ses Mémoires d'ailleurs c'est
un petit peu difficile avec Pierre
Brasseur et votre père sur le plan sur
le plan charnel elle dit nous vivions
comme de chastes orphelins ce qui vous a
pas empêché effectivement de naître un
an après le mariage malgré tout Claude
Brasseur voilà dans une enfant géniale
vous avez côtoyé j'ouvert
Cocteau Kessel
enfants du monde c'est-à-dire que on
côtoie et on vit dans le milieu de ses
parents et souvent les enfants voilà les
collègues de bureau bah oui
effectivement les collègues de bureau
nous pouvons faire c'est des gens que
vous venez de citer
je suis toujours reconnaissant mon père
de ça de ma jamais écarté
que vous avez jamais eu à rentrer dans
le métier vous êtes né dans le métier
quoi contrairement à beaucoup de gens
qu'on reçoit qui ont eu du mal à rentrer
dans le système vous vous étiez quoi oui
il y a une statistique
officiel et internationale qui coûte 70%
des enfants restent dans le même créneau
professionnel dans le même créneau
professionnels aujourd'hui chez sportif
bien sûr alors vous dites votre père m'a
toujours gardé avec moi ils ont quand
même mis en pension oui c'est très
malheureux en pension
et moi un peu et c'est une
PPC très désagréable que je n'ai pas
honte de raconter je suis d'une
génération où
adolescent pendant l'occupation qui fait
que j'avais peur parce que bref qui dit
peur dit aux dit que j'ai pissé au lit
très tard
et au collège je devais avoir une
dizaine d'années et à la première
récréation du matin on nous faisait
tourner autour de la cour de récréation
sous les rires des enfants parce que les
enfants ne sont pas toujours tendres
avec le drap accroché autour du Couillet
du pipi de la nuit
et puis un jour un jour c'est vrai j'ai
les
branche par terre j'ai attrapé la
branche et puis j'ai commencé à faire le
clown faire le coup mais en allant
faisait d'Artagnan je me servent cette
cape et je me suis rendu compte que les
enfants riait mais il ne riez plus du
tout de la même façon c'est-à-dire
qu'avant irriguer contre nous et d'un
seul coup ils se sont mis à lire avec
nous ça a été déjà quelque chose je vous
ai très volté alors la punition a été
supprimée mais l'humiliation dans votre
esprit n'a pas été effacé non c'est
pas agréable à vivre
les études vous font chier la vérité
vraiment carrément il y a que la
création qui m'amusait parce que elle a
récréation qu'est-ce qu'on fait on fait
l'acteur on joue aux gendarmes c'est ce
que je continue alors vous rentrez vous
rentrez comme photographe à Paris Match
il y a une anecdote qui est absolument
extraordinaire un jour vous partez en
Hollande avec Walter Caron qui est un
grand photographe et vous partez en
Hollande les digues des polders avaient
cédé d'être en 55 voilà et la Hollande
était entièrement inondée et donc vous
arrivez là-bas avec Walter Caron donc
faire des photos pour match et il y
avait déjà une centaine de journalistes
Aaron je le voyais il déballe pas ses
appareils puis
ils se prêtment et puis il me dit son
assistant on attendait ce qui me gêne
des termes trouve-moi un chat
trouve-moi un chat alors bon je suis
parti dans la nature j'ai trouvé un chat
et puis il a fallu tu vois l'arbre il y
avait un arbre au milieu de cette
immense étendue d'eau il m'a dit fou moi
le chat
sur l'arbre
circuler le fait la photo puis on est
reparti ça a été la photo la plus vendue
l'inondation de Hollande c'était déjà de
la mise en scène une belle histoire mais
alors voilà vous faites le photographe
pour match évidemment grâce aux
relations Xavier par votre famille c'est
relativement facile de faire du people
et un jour vous allez voir Elvire
Popesco la grande Elvire Popesco pour
match et elle vous dit pauvre con tu ne
dois pas faire ce métier de journaliste
tu dois faire acteur c'est d'ailleurs
mon père qui m'avait donné le tuyau il
me dit écoute il y a un reportage qui
est intéressant à faire pour plesco
vient d'acheter le théâtre de Paris et
elle va créer une pièce de Marcel Pagnol
effectivement elle m'engagée pour jouer
trois rôles un frère de Judas
charpentier ou je sais pas quoi je vais
tout de suite trois répliques ensuite
passer au cinéma vous jouez dans le pays
d'où je viens de carnet et l'équipe de
tournage ben s'installe dans une caserne
et là les officiers vous dites bah tu
dois faire ton service mil itaire
pourquoi tu viens pas en Algérie
vous partez en Algérie un peu
inconsciemment il faut bien le dire
complètement et là vous découvrez une
autre réalité qui est la réalité de la
guerre et vous voyez des soldats qui
font des cartons sur ceux qui bravent le
couvre-feu ce qui m'a le plus frappé
c'est que cette torture était en général
exécutée par des appeler des militaires
de la vie il y avait des gars il y avait
il y avait des baroudeurs qui revenaient
d'Indochine et qui étaient aussi et eux
non c'était il y avait un malin plaisir
chez les appeler survêtu d'un uniforme
d'un seul coup
tirer dessus puis après ils allaient
vérifier c'est ma balle non c'est la
tienne ah non non c'est moi qui l'a dit
vous-même Claude Brasseur un jour comme
ça vous trouvez en face ce qu'on
appelait les faits Laga à l'époque et il
va dégainer vous dégainer avant lui vous
le tuer
exact
toute votre vie vous regretterez de ne
pas avoir eu la culture politique d'être
un objecteur de conscience
dans un collège non pas de jésuite et
Oratoriens
et effectivement la télé la radio est
formée les seuls journaux qu'on laissait
pénétrer à l'intérieur du palais des
journaux sportifs et on avait
effectivement aucune aucune aucune
culture politique en sortant du collège
me voulant embar capital culturel d'en
parler Bourdieu voilà c'est ça vous
n'aviez pas celui-là alors votre père
quand vous avez la croix de guerre il
faudra parce que évidemment ça
correspondait pas du tout à ses idées il
vous en veut à ce moment-là il m'en veut
oui il m'a envoyé une lettre en me
disant espèce de petit con tu vas pas
porter ça n'oublie jamais que quelques
secondes près une décoration c'est une
raison funèbre et oui oui
vous voulez beaucoup quand vous avez
fait le Paris-Dakar
vous avez jamais écrasé personne
[Musique]
non non non non non non non non non non
non non non non
[Applaudissements]
sur leur moto ça fait un max de Blair
aux portes du désert un paquet d'enfoiré
au vent du Ténéré ouais six fois le
Dakar quand même hein
vous on a besoin de s'entretenir faut
pas oublier que dans notre métier nous
sommes à la fois instrumentiste mais on
est aussi l'instrument vous connaissez
Brasseur
et puis un million d'années
tous les deux là parce que c'est un
sacré fêtard brasseur il est toujours
pas alcoolique mais ivrogne ce qui est
pas du tout la même chose non c'est pas
la même c'est pas de moi c'est une
définition de Prévert absolument vous
avez fait la fête ensemble Olivier il
est certain que au détour de certaines
nuits nous nous croisâment
et toujours de façon drôle
vous êtes bien fait sauter la tête vous
quand même hein
faut dire aussi une chose c'est
difficile d'aller au lit après le
théâtre c'est un peu comme si un mec
allait se coucher à 7h du soir en
sortant du bureau moi je sors du bureau
à minuit
[Musique]
alors Claude le pire est à venir
maintenant c'est l'interview nul
[Applaudissements]
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
poêlée qu'à un moment il a du mal en
tant que vieux copain de débauche vous
pouvez l'aider voilà
alors est-ce que vous préférez votre
père ou votre mère
à ces interview je vous ai prévenu je
préférais mes grands-mères
le mot le plus con en amour pour vous
c'est merci
alors
oui oui
alors heureuse
et pour vous Alain oui oui
pour toi c'est quoi le mot le plus
condamné
[Applaudissements]
imaginez que vous croisiez un
extraterrestre le matin comme ça on a
acheté des cigarettes il vous dit tu es
qui toi vous lui répondez quoi et toi
si vous étiez en vente dans un sex-shop
vous seriez quoi en vente dans un
secteur
un préservatif mais je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que c'est exactement la
même chose que l'émetteur en scène les
préservatifs ça rassure quand on en a un
mais quand il y en a pas qu'est-ce que
c'est bon
alors maintenant une question nulle qui
m'a été envoyé par email parce que vous
pouvez m'envoyer des questions
évidemment par Jim de Béthune savez-vous
pourquoi les abributs n'abritent pas les
bus
[Rires]
bravo pour la question si vous aviez un
perroquet chez vous vous lui
apprendreiez quelle phrase tu as fermé
le gaz
tu as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête
la coco je lui apprendrai à se taire
à qui attribueriez-vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes un vieux qui
se tape des jeunes ou un jeune qui tape
sur des vieilles le vieux qui se tape
des vieilles oui
alors vous préfériez passer la nuit avec
Anne Sinclair
lors Sinclair ou Bret Sinclair
je vais dire à 5h parce que je connais
pas les deux autres ça lui fera plaisir
et vous perso
je veux pas passer la nuit toute façon
non moi j'ai toujours vu ces choses là
comme une livraison
il y a une heure d'arrivée une heure de
départ
tenez vous les chiens
une question de Michel Drucker que j'ai
piqué
c'est ce qu'on dit généralement
vous êtes bientôt le voir donc je vais
bientôt le voir entraîner
conversation avec mon père au Théâtre de
la Porte Saint-Martin avec Serge Azana
vicius mesdames messieurs non et là
Sardou il est moyen là quand même non
mais je trouve ça très courageux de
sapin parce qu'il aurait pu faire et
joindre le monde
je trouve ça plutôt sympathique et en
plus il fait il fait une innovation pour
la première fois un théâtre privée va
ouvrir ses portes le mardi à 19h30 bah
Michel Sardou c'est une ordres et si tu
veux venir tu es le bienvenu et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater le Inna
larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu